this is a stunning story I don't know if
this is an example of poetic justice or
just desserts or of karma if you believe
in that type of thing I don't or of
irony I don't know what to call it but
one of the architects of a proposed
Virginia transgender bathroom bill those
horrible waste of time pointless
discriminatory bills has lost to the
first transgender legislature in the
Virginia State House race
Danika Rome became the first transgender
person to be elected to Virginia state
legislature ever and she defeated a 13
term member of the House of Delegates
but not just any 13 term member she
defeated Robert G Marshall I call him
Bob Bob Marshall who not only once
called himself the chief homophobe but
also proposed a transgender bathroom
bill which fortunately died in committee
didn't go any further than that in
Virginia but very similar type of bill
to the ones that have been around the
country and that have been an absolute
disaster similar in some ways to that
disastrous hb2 bill in North Carolina
that's been so terrible for North
Carolina's economy Marshall during this
campaign refused to have any debates
with the 33 year old transgender
Challenger insisting on referring to
Danica as him and he during the campaign
after losing Bob Marshall declined
interview requests and when Danica Rome
the winner was asked about Bob Marshall
she said I don't attack my constituents
Bob Marshall is my constituent now that
is like the most respectful way of
saying I won you lost you're beneath me
to even talk about that I maybe have
ever seen in politics a really sweet
victory and what I was thinking about as
I was seeing these results roll in was
what if anything does this tell us about
the so-called culture wars and there's a
couple different interpretations right
one interpretation would be that culture
wars may not be a way to win elections
anymore in other words it's not that it
was that the trans issue impacted voters
but rather that it wasn't relevant to
voters
it was everything else about these
candidates that swung the election I
don't think that's it not a hundred
percent anyway there's another
interpretation about a transgender
candidate defeating a transphobic
candidate in the state of Virginia is
that the transgender stuff does matter
the cultural cultural stuff does matter
and that the vote is actually a direct
rejection of the sort of alt-right
social conservatism that Bob Marshall
represented even in moderately read
Virginia and the message from the voting
is homophobia is not going to be
tolerated transphobia is not going to be
tolerated but I also don't think that
it's that 100% either it's sort of a
combination and this was a member of the
House of Delegates whose presence was
increasingly seen as sort of tired and
outdated the outrageous social
conservatism didn't help the anti-trump
Ian blowback that's sort of taking place
that we're seeing in races like these
was probably also a factor and he was
out campaigned right the bottom line is
that Danica roam significantly out
fundraised Bob Marshall and just
generally ran away better campaign and
it's also worth noting that the key
issue of Danica rome's campaign was
traffic issues traffic issues which
really tells us this was a local
political race the commuting issues in
this part of Virginia are nightmarish
and that is why maybe even if the
cultural issues do matter to people on
paper right if you were to call voters
and say what's your feeling on this
issue of transgender bathrooms or
whatever right they might have a strong
opinion but when it comes down to it
this is the House of Delegates the
issues are what are you doing for me at
the local level or what might you do for
me and Rome is a former journalist she
gathered the concerns of the electorate
it was a small enough race where she
could actually speak to people and
reliably build a platform around what
matters to the people that might vote
for her ultimately on Election Day and
she did it and she won and this is the
way it's supposed to work this is a
district that previously has gone to the
Republican Party not by a small margin
and Danica roam a historic win an
interesting win in terms of whether it
means anything for the midterms there's
a case to be made that these stay
Rep state legislature House of Delegates
I pray PSA's don't really serve as a
barometer for national midterm elections
which we will have in November November
of 2018 but very solid results for
Democrats yesterday on a number of
levels congratulations to Danica Rome
and we can say bye-bye to Bob Marshall I
predict you're not going to see any
transgender bathroom bills proposed by
danika Rome but maybe I'll be shocked by
that and end up being wrong I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show we'll take
a break I will be moving Jenga pieces
after the break
today's program is made possible in part
by Blue Sky binaries blockchain Academy
blockchain the technology on which
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies can be
based many people not aware of both the
power and the risks that are carried by
blockchain technology I've only started
to get into this a little bit buying a
little bit of Bitcoin here and their
dollar cost averaging but a lot of
people myself included believe that
blockchain technology is just too
complicated to understand but the truth
is it doesn't have to be that way the
blue sky binary blockchain Academy from
leading financial education firm blue
sky binary explains how blockchain works
and it can work in addition to existing
knowledge that you have about blockchain
it's for both beginners and active
cryptocurrency users alike with the
course students are taken through a
series of topics which ultimately will
deliver a very solid understanding of
how blockchain works and help students
realize the potential future uses of
blockchain technology we've talked about
this in the pharmaceutical world we've
talked about this in the IT security
world many many possibilities for
blockchain and the course includes video
on-demand online tests access to a
community of traders and blockchain
enthusiasts and at blue sky binary.com /
David you can register to get a free
three-day trial which includes access to
the first module of the course for you
to evaluate the overall quality and
decide if you want to stick with it get
a free three
a trial at blue sky binary.com / David